in this tutorial I want to show you how
to draw a great-looking mechanisms and
schemes in ChemDraw
first of all I go to the file menu and
make sure that I have an ACS document
the default settings for ChemDraw are
kind of wonky so you'll want to go to
the apply document settings from this
ACS document now if you're a grad
student in your PI has certain settings
that's they want to specify for you you
may need to go into the document
settings yourself and then go into this
drawing setting if they want a different
length of the bond you can adjust that
here you can make your line width
thicker and you're bold with thicker you
can change the size of the text captions
that'll be the default so that's really
great I sometimes feel like that
10-point font is really small so for
some presentations I like to size this
up for the for some PowerPoint
presentations I sometimes like to make
my bold width and line with exaggerated
a little bit so my structures just
appear a little bit more solid on my
slides the atom labels are actually when
you type on to the molecule what your
atom labels are going to look like so
you can set these to be bigger or
smaller whatever you want that being
said I'm just gonna use the default ACS
style settings for this tutorial now
let's draw the diekmen cyclization if
you're not familiar with this mechanism
no worries I'm gonna take you through it
and really this tutorial is just to
learn about the settings that we have
now if you know the name of the
structure you're drawing the easiest
thing is to go into this convert name to
structure I have this key command
memorized because when you make a career
out of chemistry you really want to be
able to do this quickly all the time so
I'm gonna go ahead and type in the name
of the molecule that I want and here's
my starting material since we're drawing
a mechanism we'll be using a lot of
arrows so I'm gonna double click this
and this brings it out I am let's see
using ChemDraw 16 if you had any
versions previous when you clicked on
this little arrow that brought it out
you could actually just drag from here
and drag this out into your workspace if
you wanted to but now it's a double
click in chem
sixteen my final product is gonna be a
ring so I'm gonna go ahead and draw that
and the default puts this point up if I
click and hold I could orient this in
any way so if I wanted my flat bond
right here I can do that as well but I'm
just gonna undo that I'm gonna end up
with a carbonyl here the best way to
draw is by clicking on the bond if you
click on a bond it'll give you a hundred
and twenty degree angles between
everything so ChemDraw does that for you
double-clicking on this bond here is
going to give me my double bond and then
I can either select this a or I can
quickly double click and put my oxygen
here again if I just click right here
the bond will go in this direction and
then I can draw another bond now say I
didn't want this bond pointing down say
I wanted it pointing up I can just undo
so ctrl Z or command Z click again and
it puts my bond in the opposite
direction as long as I don't do any
other things in between so see how that
just reoriented it if I undid it again
it'll go down if I undo it again
I can orient it up very convenient now
I'm gonna put my double bonded oxygen
here and then I need to add my o methyl
now say I clicked and dragged and I
ended up putting my bond and this kind
of weird geometry here this doesn't look
good and we want to make really good
looking schemes so I'm just gonna go
ahead and click on this which selects my
structure and then I can go to clean up
structure now this kind of oriented this
downward maybe I wanted it up so here
I'm gonna go ahead and take this up
select it again clean up the structure
and then it goes into a better geometry
in the location where I've sort of
nudged it to now I'm going to draw in my
reagents in the first step I'm going to
use n a ome sodium methoxide to do my
deprotonation and then after this
reaction we end up with an anion so in a
second step we're going to need to add
an acid
now see I have this this too looks
really bad here it's supposed to be sub
scripted and I could go in select it and
you know subscript these things manually
but there's an easy way to do this and
apply it to everything that you're doing
this little ch2 button here is going to
super and subscript mostly appropriately
so once in a while with like a metal or
something I'll have to add in super and
subscript about the formula button it's
very smart and it'll pretty much know
what you're doing okay now I want to
draw a nice arrow under here that spans
my reagents we might want to Center that
and actually there's a really great way
to Center this say I want to make these
objects aligned in their centers I can
go to object aligned and I can do
left-right centers and you see that
moved it over a little bit now maybe I
think that the way the arrow is this
this L is a little bit too close so I
might just go ahead and nudge this over
with my arrow keys to where I think it
looks good also we may want to align
this arrow with the middle of this
molecule in this direction and have
these two things aligned so I'm going to
just select and then I'm going to do
shift select so I have that selected and
maybe I want to select my arrow with
this and get everything aligned in the
middle now I go back to my object menu
align top bottom centers okay now
everything is aligned top to bottom just
right in the middle
I might nudge this down so it's not too
close to my reagents here and we're
looking pretty good to start okay now
I'm going to quickly show you how to
draw the diekmen cyclisation mechanism
and I'm going to show you how to use
this pen tool to make really
cool-looking arrows for your mechanism
arrows and we'll use the regular arrow
tools as well I'll begin by copy pasting
this compound down here my first step is
going to be a deprotonation so I'm going
to draw a hydrogen o and that looks kind
of weird I maybe I want that
coming down but now my bond angles look
a little bit strange because I wanted to
show both of these hydrogen's so
remember we go to structure clean up the
structure and now these are at great
bond angles since I have four
substituents on this carbon shown
now I want to show sodium methoxide so
I'm just gonna show methoxide because
that's what's relevant for our mechanism
now I can click on this and I should
actually show you one more thing I
always have my chemical warnings turned
off and one of my chemistry friends says
that's like drawing without spellcheck
so you want that maybe on while you're
learning to do mechanisms because this
is showing me something is wrong
I have ome and that is not chemically
that's not a good structure now when I
take my negative charge and put that
wherever I want to I'm just gonna kind
of orient it down here somewhere near my
oxygen the red highlight it goes away
it's telling me that I've done a good
job that now my structure looks correct
so leaving those chemical warnings on
will help you not make mistakes early on
okay now I can take one of my arrows and
maybe the flattest one is gonna look
good here so it's not quite pointing
toward my hydrogen and that's okay what
I'm gonna do after I draw the arrow is
kind of oriented in the direction that I
want maybe use my arrow keys so we'll do
just kind of a combination of this
nudging to get my arrow where I want to
now I can go over here and I want to
show this bond becoming a negative
charge on my carbon now it's not really
pointing at my carbon so I had chosen
this arrow here maybe I want it to be a
little bit more curved so I can go ahead
oh and that points very nicely to my
carbon unfortunately it's traversing
this carbon maybe you'd want to orient
that a little bit differently but I
think this is okay for our purposes in
this tutorial let me show you how to do
a really fancy arrow sometimes I like to
use the pen tool and I like to put three
dots so I'm going to put an anchor point
here in Anchor Point here and then one
here if I right click on this line I can
put a full arrow at the end and now this
can be used to make a mechanism arrow so
this is kind of fancy it gives you a
nice curve you can kind of orient it how
you want and
when you deselect it you're gonna have
this kind of wavy looking arrow maybe I
think that's a little bit too close to
my hydrogen so I'll just nudge it to
where I think it looks good and then
adjust my methoxy group appropriately oh
we just want to maybe shift and deselect
this piece and now we have this kind of
nice wavy looking arrow and I always do
three anchor points I usually have
better control over where the arrow goes
when I do it that way if you get any
more you start to get sort of funny
angles so that's a nice way to make a
good arrow will show a nice equilibrium
arrow and then I'm going to copy paste
my structure to show the anion that I
form from the deprotonation so if I just
hold my cursor over this I can press
delete on my keyboard or I can actually
click on it and select it but when
you're deleting a lot of things you can
just hover over them and delete but I
want to undo that because I want to keep
my molecule here okay here's our anion
so I just drag on that carbon so this
stays associated with the carbon and
then I can go ahead and maybe do
something like this see if I can make
that look good
so now we have a nice little curved
arrow coming up like this I don't know
if that's any better that I can do with
the arrow tool so let's just go ahead
and select this arrow tool point it
toward my carbon maybe do our little
adjustments to really make sure it's
pointing where we want to make our bond
and then I can show this double bond
coming up and becoming a lone pair on
oxygen all right let me show you a trick
that I think is pretty cool so I'm gonna
copy paste my structure again you might
be like wait a second you you want to
form a ring you got to draw this
differently but what I like to do is
just take whenever I'm forming rings out
of especially out of long chains if you
just take the position where you were
making your bond and attach it to the
position where your bond is going and
then of course I need to get rid of my
double bond here and put on a negative
charge then I can just go through and
I'm going to use the key command for
clean up structure and this can get into
a pretty nice orientation for you the
more you clean it the more it'll go into
other other directions I don't really
want to show stereochemistry here so I'm
just gonna go over these bonds my
negative charge kind of ended up in a
weird spot so here I just have these
bonds and that was kind of hard so you
see how it made that connection there so
I could just zoom in to click on bonds
better and then zoom back out and I like
to kind of stay at 150 percent helps me
see it pretty well
you
all right now I'm gonna show you a very
useful trick but what I'm gonna do here
is change my reagents because HCl is
kind of boring but I want to show you
how we can expand labels in ChemDraw so
say you have a chemical abbreviation
you're like oh I'm so lazy I want to
show this mechanism well but I don't
want to draw out sulphuric acid
well what we can do is just take our
chemical abbreviation pop this right
over here now with this selected is
using the selection tool will go to
structure expand label and there we have
sulfuric acid perhaps we want to show
this proton so we can show our arrows
effectively so we'll draw this bond out
now we can grab one of our less curved
arrows we'll put that right here of
course we can always move this other
partner
shoulders becoming a lone pair on oxygen
and now we've arrived at our final
product
you
pop a negative charge on there my
chemical warning is telling me to and if
I wanted to just put in a little + or
something like that now maybe I was
really anal about this and I want to
make sure everything is very well
aligned we can select this do our object
align top bottom centers we could do
this over this part of the scheme we
could align right edges over here if we
were really worried about it but I think
we have a pretty good looking mechanism
drawn so I hope you learn something if
you did give me a like give me a
subscribe I'm gonna be working on a few
more ChemDraw videos in the near future
so if you're interested in learning this
program hopefully I can help KP here if
you learn something give me a thumbs up
on the way out and for more chemistry
subscribe to my channel